a lot of people in the chat talking
about ghost recon Aaron you and Jake
Decker recently got the chance to play
the co-op's sandbox which is the part
I'm excited about for the game and I
think a lot of people because at e3 we
play the story mode I think it was two
more ruk editor played it was not too
thrilled with it but you also said the
writing was kind of like frat boy ish
let's talk about the story really quick
before we get into what you like about
the game okay yeah I like just weave so
we played for hours we played on the ps4
pro just to clarify the single player
and the multiplayer on the same game
it's just whether you all have your
friends take over the your buddies or
not so yeah like while lands there's two
games here there's two separate
experiences there's the one with your
friends which I loved and I thought was
incredible um the sandbox was so good
and just the moments you have to like
the nail buddy moments you have words
like you're about to die and like over
the radio your friends like I got this
and you see like a shot from a hilltop
take out the guy who's about to kill you
and then your friend buzzes in with a
little bird like right as you get
revived and you get in and then you peel
out and like Dodger Sam and like go fly
off and do something else that part I
loved and I thought was incredible like
it delivered some of the things I've
wanted to do with friends and like even
games like karma for a long time sure
the barrier to entry was so high that I
just could never get a group of friends
together to do it right for how much it
looks like they're going for realism in
this well are they I mean Ghost Recon
has always been is well with feature
soldier obviously they went to the
future and now they are they going for
more realistic bent in this Columbia
because you're battling like drug
cartels I wonder if it's gonna be some
sort of actual you know social
commentary on I mean future future
soldier in and open worlds accurate now
the the story which you asked me about I
thought in the first four hours was just
straight-up bad um so you like landon
Central American everybody in Central
America completely trusts you which is
weird because like there's a long
history of American
engine and things going really shitty in
Central America and like on top of that
it's just like it's just super like team
america world police and it's not
self-aware and like everybody's just
always cracking out of place dick jokes
and like yeah it's that you know it's
that plot like hey if we just go kill
all the drug dealers everything's gonna
turn out great in bolivia it's just the
complete like lack of awareness of
events in central america and how crappy
the war on drugs have been and like
again from a story perspective there are
ways that you can do this that are more
impactful for example if the soldiers
start if the soldiers know that history
which they would if they're elite delta
operatives and start questioning why
they're there or if they're going to
have any impact or you can go the call
of duty like a c-130 mission where it's
super clinical language to the point
where these people come across is like
disconnected from the people who they're
killing like there's ways to write a
game like this where in addition to the
fun stuff you're doing there's impact on
the player like some of that is because
this game is completely nonlinear so
there you do not have to do the story in
any order you can do it completely out
of order okay and like I get that puts
developers in a bit of a bind where it's
hard to build character when players can
just screw off and do anything at any
time yeah so I don't know like they have
this challenge they have this great
sandbox and they got motorcycles whoa
wait did you yeah Bolivia South America
a few people are pointing out what did
you say centralized a central yeah the
latest South America died just to
clarify um so it from what did you ever
play um did you play future soldier I
did you play that co-op mode that was
sort of like a horde mode but every five
waves you had to infiltrate stealthily
and kill everybody you had synced shots
in that so I'm wondering if it kind of
feels like future soldier in an open
world but with a little more emerging
gameplay I think it's exactly future
soldier in an open world okay sounds
cool because I actually liked feature
soldier more than I think the average
person yeah and again like I'd kind of
thought the story was mediocre and the
writing was kind of bad but as soon as
you get your friends in there it's it's
a great game like it is actually a
really really fun game and it
like you know again like you see here
you're assaulting a base at night with a
lightning storm you are like using your
night vision goggles you're scouting
with your recon drone and you're
planning combined darkness combined
armed assaults with your friends like
coming in with little bird helicopters
dusting off on a rooftop like dropping
off a sniper on a hillside that aspect
of this game like how that's what made
it the experience that's what made the
four hours for me is it um what do I say
for the actual this is their PvP in the
game uh Adam aid day aight i am on a
Twitter sorry if I mispronounced Matt
was asking if there will be PvP in this
game at all this to me there will be
some sort they haven't talked about it
and so we don't know but you know again
this game has a lot of potential I think
there's only a couple games out there
that do combined arms multiplayer like
battlefield and I'm not saying that they
would go that direction in the future
with this game but doing pvping in an
open world environment I think is I mean
that you know jet the people of mod
modded just cause 2 and 3 to have
multiplayer sure and I think this game
could also benefit from it hold on Just
Cause 3 has multiplayer now in a mod
they modded and yeah how does that work
it's in the engine yeah i mean by that i
mean are there tanks flying around with
mines attached to them and people flying
into said tanks I mean with their own
minds it is just cos ooh if I imagine it
sweet so I know what I want to do after
the show now do you think ghost recon
will turn out like the division did last
year asks dent gamer votes the game
looks promising but then again the
division was also super hyped it's funny
as soon as the division came out we had
a traffic spike in people searching for
grocery gone wild lands because I think
we all know the division for a lot of
people was way too much of an RPG and
not enough of a shooter and this game is
a shooter which i like i love the gun
customization it had some of my favorite
weapons and rifles you have to go
through the world and collect all the
Scopes and weapon parts and then you
take him in a gunsmith but also like a
boss showed up there was a mission we
did through a tunnel that was really fun
we started with back home
because you can drive anything in this
game right um except for llamas which I
can't hold against the devs but I kind
of wanted to drive a llama jake deckard
so yeah like right here so that little
cross that was the boss and he I
accidentally kill them he he walked into
a gunfight and I hit him with an errand
like 320 grenade round and he died
instantly he was walk into a gunfight
hey where did I leave my foot there's
all the cocaine he was hot dad oh you
guys seen my croquet mallet oh did you
um rien on Twitter was saying did you
get a sense of how big the world was
yeah obviously all open worlds now are
big but like did it seem did you get a
sense of it being pretty vast did you
get a chance to look at the mini-map or
anything yeah the we played two regions
like maybe a tenth of the game we spent
about four hours there it's weird the
size of a world is usually a good
talking point for developers but it has
pros and cons because the problem with
an open world game is you have to fill
it with stuff like this is a general
Ubisoft challenge in all of their games
and if you make the game too big and you
fill it with too much boring stuff or
you make too much stuff that distracts
people from the main quests or you
sacrifice you know the textures up close
in this game weren't very good but like
the environmental effects at a distance
like lightning storms and flamingos you
know you flying through a flock of
flamingos with your helicopter or just
the things in the distance we're all
gorgeous but the things up close we're
kind of yeah man so I don't know yeah
it's a massive world they're saying it's
the biggest one I've ever made that
comes with pros and cons mm-hmm more
playtime more things to do question is
the big question is always how well did
you fill that world with stuff and how
fun is that stuff to do yeah you can
make Chicago and watch dogs one but if
there aren't that many people won't feel
like a city that's why I like the
division i thought it was kind of boring
that way it was this beautiful city with
no people in it yeah then i had no
antivirus right yeah yeah I guess they
justified that but I don't know I didn't
find the division to fun but I haven't
played since like what they've done a
year of updates and now it's just a
totally different game for what I hear
their survival DLC literally is a
different game right hmm yeah that's
how I want to play the game when I I
said this all throughout the year in the
office and also in my free time and also
on the lobby people who have been here a
lot I'm sure goob shoe rhyaz probably
saying has heard this before but I've
been meaning to play more the division
since release day by the way is almost a
year ago is like for ya I still want to
like me and you were the ones is saying
like I love the post-apocalyptic
aesthetic in New York I love like that
kind of ragtag group of people fighting
back and I tried playing the game and I
mechanics just totally kind of screwed
it up for me unfortunately well I think
that game got sunk on just a general
sense of unfairness like I think the
mechanics I think even the cover
mechanics were unfair to the players mmm
you had no fine control over coming up
and over cover you get shot during
animations going in out of cover there
was no crouched there was no prone right
like and then you get the dark zone in
other players with better gear would
instantly kill you and not even take
your stuff like you didn't want to take
what I had you just did to be a dick
just give you a taste of their taint and
move on yeah so David Fox in the twitch
chat with just asking Aaron how easy is
it to kind of coordinate with your team
because in the e3 demo obviously Ubisoft
was there all converging on one base at
a time as a cohesive unit did it seem
that easy or like how does it kind of
keep the team together in this massive
open world that they can you have like
one person in each corner so there are
from what you put there are actually
really cool mechanics in the game that
give you situational awareness when you
each of you can pick a target so if
you're trying to do like a four-person
zinc shot each of you can designate a
target and everybody else on your team
sees what target that you are aiming at
and they can also see if you're not
aiming at that target so if you all
designated target and somebody's about
to initiate a countdown which you can do
with a button press or just countdown
yourselves okay if you see a circle go
over one of the one of the guys who
you've targeted you know that you're
your buddies screwing around and not
aiming at that guy so it's like what
Steve yeah or like yeah I mean that's a
closed military try to use last names so
you're not saying like take the shot dog
yeah Jake Decker video producer here who
played the co-op with you was just
telling um David Fox if i'm not mistaken
who asked the question that you get a
notification when they want to do a
mission and then you can accept and fast
yeah so we like that we found the
easiest thing to do was to break there's
four people in co-op we broke off into
teams of two and like talk between teams
of two because honestly sync shotting
with two peoples way easier um I mean
there's always that chance of somebody
to go full Leroy Jenkins when you're
trying to do a stealth run because the
stealth has a lot of good mechanics to
it and there's a lot of planning that
can go into it and if you screw it up I
was impressed with how hard the AI
pushed back it's like GTA they'll just
kill they'll kill you eventually so you
either have to do the stealth route or
you have to have an exit plan okay um
and how much you accomplished in the
meantime how much stuff you get done in
the base is kind of up to you and how
stealthy or not stealthy or quick you
decide to do it ok so the it was pretty
easy with the right crowd when you're
playing with other people yeah seems
like the division kind of it could be
make or made a break made or broken by
who you're playing with if you're
pulling with someone you know or like
left for dead or something I know you
can also just use now that I think of it
like you can be in the same world with
your friends and choose not to do
missions with them right so you can
actually be just doing other stuff and
then it's like it was just left on the
d-pad join up and go do something
together and then go off and do whatever
else you want that was pretty pretty
seamless and easy cool so in general it
seems like wild lands at least from your
perspective right now co-op sandbox is
where it's at as opposed to the kind of
more less than optimistic story yeah and
again we know we played the first four
hours there's a chance that maybe
there'll be a story arc later on in the
game that kind of points out shooting
drug dealers doesn't solve problems yeah
like the movie traffic Sicario pretty
much every movie about drugs drug trade
but the coop is doing stuff that I love
when you're with your friends okay cool
you and Jake also did I think it's up
now on the site on gamespot the six
things you should know about ghosts r
you kind of wild land so people watching
right now you can go check that on the
site right now you can watch that for
more in-depth conversation about the
game and let us know you think we'll do
our best to look through the comments
and kind of answer any other questions
that weren't answering the feature or on
this segment
[Music]